but doesn't code have to have a
coder no of course it
doesn't that doesn't make any
sense just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
wasalam alikum welcome to this reaction
video we're going to be watching Piers
Morgan and Dawkins it's going to be
interesting what do you think of this
Ali I'm excited to see the cultural
Christian atheist see what he has to
bring and you know is he going to defeat
P Morgan because you know he's more
senior you know in knowledge The Clash
of Titans when scientists and
philosophers reason from evidence they
typically use a method of reasoning that
has a technical name it's called
inferring to the best explanation where
the best explanation is one that where
you're invoking a cause which has the
kind of powers that would be required to
explain the phenomenon of interest and
you correctly pointed out in your
conversation with him that when you get
back to that what physicists of often
call The Singularity the point where
matter space time and energy begin to
exist the materialist is really up
against a huge conundrum because prior
to the origin of matter there is no
matter to do the causing that's what we
mean by the origin of matter that that's
where it starts right and so if you want
to invoke a cause which is sufficient to
explain the origin of matter you can't
invoke matter you see Richard D this is
the the nub of I think my whole issue
with your position on this and you can
respond obviously to what you just heard
in a moment but when you go back to the
very
start what is there before that and that
I think I asked you last time and
Professor Meer brought that up again as
being the floor in your position which
is what is there before it starts what
is nothing this is a question for a
physicist not a biologist but what I
would answer to Professor Meyer is that
we need to explain complexity in terms
of Simplicity and of course it's true
that I cannot say what was there before
the Big Bang okay so he started off and
the first thing that he said with
respect Professor Dawkins is false we
have to explain
complexity with Simplicity what's the
evidence for that they call it the
aram's razor but how do we know that
that is true if we look at something
right say you are studying the atom it
looks pretty simple you got all these
atoms that make up the world yet what
did physicists Discover at the beginning
of the 20th century they discovered
quantum mechanics they discovered that
actually When You observe a particle it
acts differently to when you don't
observe it young slay experiment so the
world turned out to be far more complex
than we thought so this this assumption
that everything has to be broken down
into simple terms what's the evidence
for that there's none yeah exactly
exactly I mean he he talks about like um
what's the other guy's name Steven Meer
yeah St me said you know it's like they
just pointing back to the first cell or
whatever it is that doesn't explain
anything you know you're just poting
back to the matter we're not talking
about that we're talking what created
that cell which is the question but they
keep saying oh yeah the first cell was
complex and it replicated itself in
order for it to replicate itself it has
to have design in the first place you
know so yeah absolutely and why one cell
but also going back to naturalism and
materialism it can't explain matter
itself yes because it's it's it's
insufficient but I just want you to add
something else look Richard Dawkins
knows his stuff when it comes to biology
obviously he does but philosophy is a
different thing and Steven Meyer comes
from a philosophy of science back he has
a PhD from Cambridge and Michael Roose
who's a well-known atheist he is
somebody that said that reading Richard
Dawkins book The God Delusion made him
embarrassed to be an atheist and also
said about him that he would fail at an
introductory class of philosophy so the
problem here is not his science but it's
his overall thinking philosophic he's
been popularized physicists sometimes
tell us that the word for before doesn't
even mean anything before the Big Bang
but whatever it was it can suddenly
invoke doesn't it have to someone well
someone as logical as you are I believe
you are you know you think about this
all very logically a logical mind surely
has to appreciate that before the Big
Bang there has to have been something
before then otherwise what is nothing
talk a physicist will tell you that they
that what do you what do you tell tell
you so when he says a physicist a
physicist will tell you who is he really
referring to he's referring to the likes
of La Krauss what happened to Lawrence
Krauss yeah Jan so the fact is you know
he wrote a book a universe from nothing
nothing is something you guys can see
the debate with Hamza sort is like you
if you're going to talk about something
as deep as the beginning of the universe
you have to speak about philosophy you
cannot just speak about physics because
that's a point at which physics and
philosophy becomes one and and and
they're so illogical I mean p calling
them logical they're not I these people
use these terms and names even like you
know rationalities rules your your
irrationality rules because I don't
understand logic right you guys are the
absolute oxymoron the opposite of that
and here look he demonstrates that when
he asks simple question simply what was
before that I mean it's it's just common
logic and he can't answer it I'm trying
to tell you what a physicist would say
first of all they would say that you
cannot use the word before for the Big
Bang time began at the Big Bang there
was no before before the Big Bang I know
it's contrary to Common Sense physicists
don't necessarily deal with common sense
well it it makes no sense does it I
that's what I mean is it you're a
logical man that cannot make sense to
you yeah so let's go back to Imam
gazali's argument the cam cosmological
argument whatever begins to exist has a
cause yes the universe began to exist
therefore the universe has a cause yes
we are not invoking anything except
basic simple logic now the problem with
Professor Dawkins and this is for
anybody that's read his book The God
Delusion is he is weak in philosophy he
may be strong in biological science but
he's weak in philosophy which is why
when it comes to someone like Piers
Morgan who's a journalist who's not a
scientist himself or a physicist or a
philosopher he can Corner him like this
and you can actually see through his
body language and his demeanor that it's
very difficult for him to speak about
this topic exactly and you know what's
really profound imagine all of the
people that left their faith be a
Christianity well
I mean just imagine them on the day of
judgment and this clown is there with
this illogical
irrational sense whatever he has yeah
and I mean just imagine the absolute
utter horror of listening to this fool
this clown that has no idea what he's
talking about cannot even explain the
basic principle except that there was
something before I mean just the utter
Devastation of losing this life and the
Hereafter because of someone like him
look at his face I mean a cultural
Christian atheist
yes the thing that we need to keep in
mind is somebody may be very good at
their field they may be very good at
zoology they may be very good at
explaining say the selfe idea which is
what Richard Dawkins is very good at but
then when it comes down to logical
issues we shouldn't think oh he has a
monopoly on thinking CU he's the Oxford
Professor we should also ask those
critical questions but they don't
because they are insecure that's why
they treat like a prophet whatever he
says it's like we are Blind Faith but
doesn't code have to have a coder
no of course it doesn't okay that
doesn't make any sense what is Piers
Morgan basically is doing he's asking a
basic question of inference the same
question which Maya is you know speaking
about in the previous interview we are
not talking about God of the gaps we are
using our minds and our past experience
to deduct that if there is a impre
design there must be a designer and if
there's a Code there must be a coder and
you know the other day when we were in
Bosnia we would you know me you and
zishan we were talking about the genetic
um the DNA strand how it can be read
from left to right or right to left it
can read read 3D and the amount of
information in it and then one of the
things that you were saying is that it
has more information than all of the
books that you'll get in a library so
all of that information we want to say
no that's an accident but here we are
watching this video and we can see
there's writing PE
Rich exactly simp as that and but look
at the confidence and the categorical
way that he's speaking no yeah not even
a possibility of maybe it's just no yeah
yeah yeah yeah Subhan Allah that's why
this the prophet said speech is like
Subhan Allah you know look how he's just
demonstrating that I mean let's see
let's see what else he's saying okay uh
Cod arises um spontaneously at the
origin of Life something very very
simple probably okay wait a minute again
this is an assumption this is not proven
this this what's the evidence for this
so he gives the answer and then he says
probably
how do you know that how do you know
there's one cell not 10 cells yeah
exactly and and information is something
yes it it's like I said before the
example that I gave it's that if if if
there is nothing yes absolute
nothingness you cannot it's irrelevant
to time time is irrelevant to equation
because the thing and the um the
elements to make that thing is not there
so how could you be talking about
probability and you know I'm not saying
he said that like you know give it
enough time but he's basically talking
about by chance how could it come how
could information AR
from nothingness it's an
impossibility all of our experience
teaches us what it teaches us that if
there is design if there's information
if there's coding we make an inference
but when it comes to the coding that we
find in the DNA we are told to switch
off yes the logic button we're told to
not be consistent and to say actually
categorically there's no design and this
is the problem when you mix biology with
philosophy but you don't actually tell
people that actually what I'm doing here
is just my own personal belief it's got
nothing to do with the biological data
cuz the biological data is there's
coding any inferences that you make any
philosophical things that you say such
as no there's definitely no designer
there's a background Assumption of
naturalism which is not being said here
exactly this is in a nutshell end on
this note is that this is kufur kufur is
basically you are hiding the truth you
are basically because of your ego
because you hate God because I think I
don't know if he said he was molested
when he was young as well I don't know
if it was him or whatever it is you hate
God and because of that anything to do
with God the truth you are hiding they
basically these individuals are the
figureheads of hiding the truth and
there's absolute sadly idiots there
following them to Hellfire I mean we
don't to repeat he's repeating himself
like a parrot I think the matter is
clear s in and the days of atheism is
over absolutely so over AB this last
I've ever do on someone like him I mean
yeah I would highly recommend for
somebody that wants to know the truth
who's sincere then what you should do is
never think to yourself somebody has a
monopoly on thinking yes he's a
professor yes he's from Oxford yes he's
an intelligent person but he can be
wrong so we should be open and skeptical
and we should have the scientific
mindset of thinking okay maybe I need to
look at somebody else's arguments as
well exactly brother and sisters hope
you enjoy that video in